Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in
chapter number 73 of the Quran
verses number 19 and 20. These are the
two final verses of this chapter.
After this chapter, inshallah we will
move on to
as many of the scholars of the
and companions
site
as the fourth chapter to be revealed to
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam.
in a very general sense
in this verse
this verse in which Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says and this is verse number 19
for
[Silence]
Allah Subhanahu Waaala.
Islam.
for
[Silence]
this statement that we spoke about last
night. verse number 19 in which Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says indeed this
these verses
are a reminder
the best of reminders the most
sufficient of reminders
he then says hence whoever wishes to
strike a path to his lord can do so
using this Quran,
this book, the Quran,
it is a
that we ask Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala to
guide us to every time we pray in every
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala taught us that
we are to say
guide us the straight path. Guide us to
it, guide us upon it, keep us on the
straight path. What is that straight
path? What is that straight path of
Allah? The path in which Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
says
this is my path. It is a straight and
broad one. So follow it and adhere to it
and do not follow the branching paths
for they will take you away from the
path of Allah. What is that straight
path? When we look into the
that the companions the
of the companions the of the
when they explain what is
in
you'll find some of them say
is the Quran others will say
is Islam others will Say
it is the way of the prophet and his
companions
etc. All of these definitions
they are different angles of the same
exact thing. They're all different
angles of the same thing. these when one
companion says
Islam and the other says it's the Quran
and the other says it's the path of the
prophets and messengers and the others
say these are all the same thing.
Why? They're just different aspects of
the same hole. If you could imagine this
building right here, if we sent out four
or five guys outside, one to each side
of the building, we said, "Tell us what
you see."
So, one says, "I see a building or a
wall going this way, going up this way,
etc." Each of them is going to have a
slightly different
a slightly different description, but
are they describing a different thing?
No. They're all describing different
angles of the same building.
Our prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
once drew a line in the sand
and then off of this line, this long
straight line,
he drew departing
short lines branching off
from this line to the right and to the
left of it.
And then he said
gesturing to the long straight line in
the middle
he said this is the path of Allah.
Then he said gesturing to the small
short lines branching off to the right
and left.
He said, "And these are the paths that
Allah warned us from taking the paths
that if we take them, they are short and
they will
depart from the path of Allah." He said,
"And at the entrance of each of these
short paths is a devil calling and
inviting and beckoning
passers by into that path."
He gave us another parable about the
path of Allah
here in this verse.
And so whoever wishes may strike a path
with these verses and this Quran to
Allah.
He said in an narration collected in by
he said
forch.
[Silence]
Jew
focus
[Silence]
in shift.
Islam.
[Silence]
for
Listen to this parable that the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam gave us of the path
of Allah.
He said, "Allah has given us a parable,
an analogy, an example,
a straight, imagine a straight and long
path.
To both sides of this path, there are
two walls all the way up and down the
sides of this path.
And in these two walls, there are open
doors all the way down.
And upon each of these doors is a
curtain
that has been drawn across the door so a
person can't see past it.
He said, "And
at the helm of this path,
there is someone there fervently
inviting people into the path, saying,
"Oh people, enter the path of Allah and
do not go astray."
And there is a warner, a caller all the
way with the person as they tread this
path.
That every time a person on the path
gets curious
and wishes to peek behind that curtain
to see what it is, what's what's back
there? All these open doors, open doors
in themselves, they're just so inviting.
And these curtains, I just want to see.
I'm not going to go off of the path. I
just want to see what's going on on the
other side.
Every time a person gets curious,
this
warner, this voice calls to them and
says, "Be careful.
Do not look behind that curtain.
If you look behind that curtain, you're
going to end up walking through that
doorway.
The prophet sallallah.aii wasallam then
explained the analogy. Have we pictured
the analogy here? Okay. So, we've got a
long straight path.
On both sides of the path running all
the way down the sides are what? Two
walls.
And in these two walls, there are open
doors. Doorways all the way down.
And drawn across each of these doorways
is a curtain concealing what's behind
it.
Perhaps one of the
most difficult
one of the most difficult
hindrances a person encounters in his
life. that is so difficult to grapple
with. Curiosity.
We hear the term curiosity killed the
cat, right? I just want to see what's
going on. I have to satisfy that urge
and curiosity.
He said, and and we have now someone at
the beginning of the path and through
the path inviting people and instructing
them as they go down the path. Come into
the path of Allah. Do not go astray.
Every time someone gets curious
and reaches for one of these curtains to
just take a peek,
they hear this overwhelming voice that
says, "Do not peek past or behind that
curtain. If you look into that curtain,
you're going to end up entering through
that door."
Then the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam explained each component of the
analogy.
He said that the path
is the path of Allah Islam.
The straight path that is the religion
of Islam. When a person is upon it, they
are upon this straight path to Allah.
And those two walls all the way down
each side of the path,
those are the boundaries of Allah that
we are not permitted to to trans
transverse or transgress.
And those open doors all the way down,
those are the prohibitions of Allah.
A person uses a prohibition of Allah to
cross the boundaries of Allah
just a person uses a door to
cross a threshold.
He says, "And the caller inviting at the
o at the opening of the door or the
beginning of the path and down the
path." That is the book of Allah, the
Quran.
And that warner
that every time someone wants to peek
behind the curtain, warns them not to
peek because if you peak, you're going
to end up
going through that door. This is, as the
prophet puts it, the warner of Allah in
the heart of every Muslim.
What is referred to often as the
conscience,
your conscience, that voice.
But this is specific to the Muslim.
That voice in the heart of the Muslim
that tells him, "Don't do this. This is
wrong. This is incorrect.
The prophet sallall.aii Wasam has told
us
that
he tells us that every human being
has a devil
that sits the sits and whispers to
him.
that devil and Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
says
and then he says and there's also with
every human being an angel that advises
look at the blessing of Allah even
tonight we listened in one of the verses
in surah inah
The second
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
"Huh?
Huh?
Forget
and
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala rhetorically
ly asks, "Does the human being really
think that he'll be left to go to waste?
All this life, all this precision,
hearing, vision, touch,
smell, intelligence,
free will,
life, death, fear, safety, happiness,
anguish, tears, smiles for nothing.
Nothing at all. And this is why
is so despicable to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
[Arabic recitation]
Actually, that was probably the best
one.
Meaning is anything that has the
anything that is inconsequential.
It's immaterial.
It it doesn't hurt. It doesn't help.
It's just a waste.
Why is one of the descriptions of the
people of of paradise
that in paradise they won't have
there will be no
folly
in paradise.
No wasted words. No nonsense.
Why is that so despicable to Allah?
Because the human being was taken
through drops. The mother and the father
have to meet each other. Drops of
secretion. And then this very very
precise
marriage of these different
the the these these different
factors come together in a very
particular set of circumstances
over a period of nine months grows and
you know goes through the stages of of
life that the fetus goes through and
then the person is born and then they're
raised and they have hearing and
smelling and a sense of taste and a
sense of touch and vision and
consciousness and then you you do what
with all this? What do you do with it?
You just waste it. It's nothing.
This is why it's so despicable to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala because it's a
waste. All of this is it's kind it's
taking Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's
creation as a game
that he didn't create the heavens and
the earth just playing for play for
sport for no good reason.
And so the human being look at how much
attention the human being has been given
here. Our prophet tells us that each
human being has a devil that is sent to
whisper and Allah has sent one of his
troops to counter that. An angel that
advises
and then you have on your right and left
what on the right and left of every
human being huh is an angel writing.
The one on the right writes the good
deeds but doesn't just sit there writing
good deeds passively. No, the one that
writes the good deeds also is constantly
giving advice
to the human being and commanding good.
And then on the left you have one
writing what? The bad deeds. And he
doesn't just passively write the bad
deeds. He also what?
forbids evil and tells you, "Hey, don't
do that. Hey, you know better. Hey,
Allah said this, right?" And then those
two angels
have are on shifts. Two for the daytime
and two for what? For the night time.
Okay. So there's four plus the angel
that is there to advise and counter the
there's five. And then Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala says
that each human being has an angel in
front of him and an angel behind him
protecting him by the will of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Those are on shifts as well. Now we're
at what? We're at nine other than the
angel that comes to put the soul into
the bo into the fetus and the angels
that come to prepare a person for death
and the angel of death that takes the
soul and the angels in the grave and the
angel. All this for no reason. Just so
you could kick back and waste all your
time chitchatting and complaining and
yapping and not learning anything. This
is why Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala takes
our existence so seriously and why we
are implored to take our existence so
seriously. Tomorrow night inshallah we
will finish this chapter verse number
20 and then we will move on to which
surah
[Silence]
Allah Subhanahu Wa'tala
Foreham.